yo dallas is uh obviously
you you have a lot to do with it being
as
big on the national map of hip-hop as it
is
now because i feel like when i was kind
of coming up like dallas like we didn't
there was the little will record my
dougie there was um shout out to darrow
what was the other dude who had a deal
[ __ ] i forget his name but he had a
big tuck big toe yeah that's dsl
dear so they hit him and tom tom
um we had um
the head miss puke and miss lucci i mean
we got miss spooky miss lucci um who had
like some big [ __ ] young nation had some
big [ __ ] going on they had like the
stanky leg [ __ ] going on yeah they had
well you had the stinky like yeah my
doggy they had yeah mr hit that whole uh
and uh walking around the club [ __ ]
everybody
yeah
prince rick uh
i didn't even know that was the dallas
record yeah a little running throw that
ass in the circle um
[ __ ]
but i feel i was gonna say like i feel
like
for a city that is like
kind of been under represented in
hip-hop right now that y'all are
on the forefront
it always feels like there's some drama
popping off between all the artists in
dallas
yeah why do you think like is it just is
it just it is what it is mentality
instead of like people want to
shine they want to shine on themselves
right a lot of [ __ ] just want
to attention all on them they don't know
how to they don't know it she is
strengthening numbers yeah because it
feels like it's like if everyone moved
in unison it would be a very like
different type of search because you
think about atlanta yeah and you know
everybody's doing records with everybody
there's
[ __ ] the migos have done songs with
everybody gucci's doing songs for
everybody two chains i mean go on and on
and on but there is so much young talent
um obviously rip to mode three you know
trap boy freddie yourself there's so
much dope talent out of dallas that um
yeah i mean i feel like
i feel the same way about jacksonville
because you see jacksonville they got a
lot of dope artists but it feels like
everybody's like trying to tear each
other down and it's like
i don't know that [ __ ] just be crazy bro
oh [ __ ] just
i don't know it just should be envious
have you because i feel like you're kind
of the first guy to really pop from this
new wave of dallas artists in a way that
you did like that's on me is a [ __ ]
smash record right so it's like did you
feel like when you first really were
getting those looks and really started
to get that national attention that you
started to feel the most hate from your
hometown of course like at first you
know
everybody gonna look but i think you
know that's kind of like everywhere so i
always get like talk from everybody i
always say man that [ __ ] happen like
they gonna love you then they're gonna
hate you then they'll probably start
back loving me again you know what i'm
saying but
i was getting a lot of love then you
know come to hate the crab in the barrel
uh crabs in the bird [ __ ] like people
want to
just use your name for the click bait
now type of [ __ ] but let me deal
with it there